[Music]
hello and welcome welcome to a wolf in
sheep's clothing I'm your host blessings
win today we present God's hand in an
actor's life ascending the ranks of
Hollywood he discovers the god of the
Bible the decisions he makes will decide
his eternal fate we welcome Eli Gore
thank you so much for being here oh
thanks for having me bless we're excited
to hear your testimony can we start with
your
childhood yeah so um I was not raised in
the Adventist faith in fact I wasn't
really ra raised within a Christian
upbringing um the only kind of exposure
that I had to Christianity when I was
younger was um I had the opportunity to
be brought into a foster family for a
period of time and that became like my
other family still to this day I look at
it like I have two families um and my
foster mother and father were Baptists
and they were very devout and they you
know they really followed it but because
I was constantly going back between
there and my biological family
um that Christian influence really
didn't take hold it didn't stick for you
yeah I didn't really feel like I was a
Christian I didn't practice and I looked
at myself as I became a teenager and and
a young person as an agnostic not that I
didn't I didn't know what what was real
and what wasn't I didn't know if God was
real or if he wasn't real I had moments
in my life where I felt maybe there was
a God but as I got even more in deeper
into high school and education I started
studying science and I started believing
more Evolution right and and big bang
and these types of theories so was were
you ever exposed to the Bible or so
actually uh not really when I was you
know in my foster mother's house she
would you know do the now I me down to
sleep prayer before bed every night and
that was kind of the uh and I knew not
to bring certain things in the home you
know I listen to really hard you know
rap music even as a four five-year-old
in my biological home but I would never
bring that stuff to that home I just
intrinsically just knew that there was
no cussing there was nothing like that
in in in that home but um I remember the
first time I recognized anything about
the Bible was when I was maybe 12 or 13
my mom was cleaning my biological mother
was cleaning her room and she had been
in the faith and praise God she's back
in the faith now but she had a period
where she was not at all in church for
about 20 something years and so during
that time she was cleaning her room and
I guess we had an old family bible she
had put it on the bed MH and I came in
the room to ask her something and I saw
this it was a large biggest book I'd
ever seen and just the words right
across the front and I I thought man I
said mom who's Holly Bibble no way
because I thought I mean she must be
super important this Holly Bibble
character if her name is so big on this
big book and my mom was just like oh my
my poor son you know my Heathen son uh
so that's how little I knew I didn't
even know a Bible to see it gotcha yeah
so let's talk about your young adulthood
how did that develop for you so um I
kind of was more interested as a young
adult in sports you know my brother was
a very successful basketball player he
was an all Canadian I'm originally from
Canada uh he played professional
basketball in Europe um probably in this
day and age where there's a lot more
social media and stuff he probably could
have played in the NBA he was really
really talented athlete and so you know
him being my older brother I wanted to
do what he was doing looking up to him
yeah so I I tried to be a basketball
player and I had you know some Talent um
not enough to go into the NBA or
anything like that and so that was one
thing and then the other thing that I
had was when I was about five years old
um my biological mom again uh she was in
school at that time which is part of the
reason she had a lot of kids five six
kids and she was going to school went
back to school as a mature student and
now she's got her getting her PhD God
bless her um but she that's why she
needed foster care was to help to help
out and um but nevertheless uh she
always had people around from the
University and artists and you know
thinkers and one of the times she had
people around the house there were some
uh producers there for a program called
Sesame Park which was our version
bootleg Sesame Street kind of thing
right I'm familiar with that one yeah
exactly and uh and so the producers had
said you know she she saw me and I was
playing or something and she said oh you
know I'm doing a program we need little
kids that can sing and dance and would
Eli be you know would you let Eli do it
and I was at that time obsessed with
Michael Jackson I thought I was Michael
Jackson like I literally thought
millions of kids did we're doing that
same thing yeah and and uh so my mom
said well ask him you know he can make
his own decisions and which is my mom
was always like that with kind of
bizarre yeah but that's just how it was
and uh for certain things and uh and so
yeah I said absolutely you know in my
head and so that's how I got into
entertainment so I would do stuff for
the CBC which is the Canadian kind of
like the BBC but it's Canada uh and then
I would go and do Sports and I would
kind of do some school stuff but that
was kind of my track all the way through
school all the way into uh you know 17
or 18 when I graduated and then at that
point I had such a resume for acting and
I was realizing I wasn't going to be a
professional athlete um and I wasn't
sure if I wanted to go to school so I
said you know what let me
see what I can do with this acting thing
so I moved to Toronto and uh and started
to pursue my professional acting career
and how did that go for you uh it was
interesting you know I got into the
Union right before I left and my
sister's husband had been doing
background acting and stuff in Toronto
and he was always kind of telling her
you know whenever they would talk about
him doing this or quitting or whatever
he'd always say you know if I could just
get in the union then you know then it
would all open up for me it would all
open
up so I think my sister was had it in
her head once I told her I was in the
union you know oh it's just going to
yeah it's all going to happen right now
so uh so she was willing to have me come
stay with her and then I that same
producer from when I was a kid knew some
an agent in town and so I was able to
kind of get set up get an agent and have
a place to stay but I wasn't any good at
acting you know at all I was a terrible
actor you know I didn't know my lines I
wasn't ever prepared I didn't have any
craft you know I was just a young guy
who' had some experience you use the
word craft that's interesting yeah it is
interesting yeah I never thought of that
because it is casting spells even the
language that is you know that describes
acting it's cast for the people who are
involved in it right there is a
television someone is telling you the
vision that they want the audience to
see that's right so at what point did
you take it seriously and and invest
into it so I was in Toronto for quite a
few years just doing commercials and
little getting little jobs here and
there when I could um but I went away to
Africa and you know we don't have the
time in this one to get into all the
details but essentially I was traveling
there and I had a a very near-death
experience and um at that time by chance
well by Providence I was reading the
Bible as I was traveling through because
I was considering quitting acting going
back to school and um and attending a
program at Kings College in Nova Scotia
called the foundational year program and
on that they had a list of books
foundational year books that are the uh
foundational books of Western culture
and
civilization and so it had Socrates and
ilad and all these books and I said I'm
going to be in Africa you know a whole
bunch of things happened for me to be
traveling over there but uh but I knew I
was going to be there for a while and I
said I might as well read one of these
books while I'm there and I said well
what's the biggest one it was the Bible
and so that's how I ended up reading the
Bible it wasn't it was completely an
agnostic exercise but one thing I did
say was to myself if I judge this as I'm
reading it I'll never get through it if
I'm looking at everything and saying oh
that can't be right that's not right I
knew that intrinsically or God put that
in my heart to think that and so I said
Eli just read it objectively and then
when you get to the end then you can
determine your decisions about it
judgments and criticisms and things like
that you can process it after by the
time I got to the end I was already I
believed in God and I consider myself to
be a Christian so now you're starting to
feel the power of the spirit in your
life yes but you're still betwix am I
going to exit or am I going to continue
what decision at that time you know I
had only when I by the time I got back
to Canada which was I was over there for
about six months like I said I had a
near-death experience God showed himself
to be real uh and pulled me out of the
situation and so
I'm like okay God is real but I'd only
really read the Old Testament I see so I
didn't know if I believe in Christianity
I didn't know about Jesus yet and in
Africa there's so many different faiths
there's Islam there's Christians there's
Voodoo there's so many things and
everyone's very passionate and so when I
got back you know the promise I made to
God was okay I'm going to find out who's
the real God who's the God of this Bible
that I've read who's the God that was
with me when I was in in a situation
where I couldn't get myself out and I so
I'm still acting and I I ended up
getting a show at this point I actually
started to really Train That's the other
thing when I got back I said okay if I'm
going to do acting I got to get I got to
be good or else I'm I'm not going to be
able to survive exactly so I started
practicing in my acting career like I
had in my sports career I started doing
small short films and University films
and Community plays and getting
instruction and just anything and I
started to get better I found a guy who
helped teach
me um a lot of spiritual stuff there but
believe that um but I started to get
better and I got a show um that was
shooting in my hometown of Halifax uh
and it was a show about a gospel choir
again Providence and I was we were
leaving set one day I was playing a
tenor in a in a gospel choir and I was
driving with the producer leaving set in
the set van and we started talking and I
knew he was a Christian because he had
produced this show and you know it was
based on his a little bit on his own
life and and so I said uh Andy his name
is Andy still a mentor to me today um I
said Andy you know you're a Christian
I've read the Bible why do Christians go
to church on Sunday right because the
Bible tells us the Bible tells you
clearly the sth day is the Sabbath the
seventh day God rested uh from all his
Works remember the Sabbath to keep it
holy I mean I'd read all of that and i'
already now at this point also finished
the New Testament and so there was
nothing that I had seen that should have
been pointing to for Sunday and so I
said why do Christians go to church on
Sunday genuinely just asking now I know
that in his mind well he says to me he
says well I don't go to church on Sunday
he says and I said really he said yeah
what well when we get back why don't I
come pick you up I'll take you to my
church you can check it out and I was
like yeah you know because in my head I
was like oh great this is you know I'm
trying to learn I'm trying to find out
who God is this is a great opportunity
not knowing in his head he's thinking
God has sent me this young you know
Heathen young boy you
yeah exactly to show him the truth and
so cuz at that time I was totally living
a lusious life and also reading the
Bible and and not really not knowing
that those two things couldn't even
match coexist right and so he took me to
church and it was my first experience in
a 7th Day Adventist Church I saw the
intelligence of the people I saw the uh
intelligence of how they uh divided the
word of truth how the how the word that
they read from the Bible was relevant to
the world that we're currently living in
and and that was what I was seeing when
I read the Bible for myself I was like
man they talk about the Israeli
Palestinian conflict in the Old
Testament they talk about how knowledge
is going to increase in the Old
Testament they the things when I was
reading the Bible that gripped me was
how relevant it is it is and when I was
in had any in like kind of exposure to
churches generally it felt like it was
totally irrelevant and it was like this
weird version that that wasn't what I
had read almost a Prosperity Gospel and
you're fine where you're at God takes
you as you're are and it was like it was
allegories and stories but it wasn't
anything real The Living Word it wasn't
the Living Word yeah and so uh and so as
I said I I went to that church and I
said okay this is definitely the same
church that this book applies to like
this these two things match praise God
you know and so at that point I said
okay I'm going to keep the Sabbath and
I'm at still thinking I'm going to be an
actor and I'm going to go to church and
so uh I was going to church still trying
to be an actor I ended up leaving there
going to Vancouver but I'm still
attending churches and people are trying
to give me messages about more of what
is present truth what is you know the
the full understanding of this church
and why is it it's not just a church
that goes to church on Sabbath it's a
church Remnant church that is a Remnant
church that has a that has a a a full
understanding of these last days and the
sanctuary message and prophecy people
are trying the Three Angels message and
people were trying to give me that but
there were also people in the church
that were saying you don't need to
listen to that and so from an outsider
coming in Wheats in the tears exactly
and I'm thinking well a prophet what if
I know that the Bible says stuff about
false prophets it also said test the
prophets but I didn't against the think
of that exactly and and you know and and
I'm saying well I have the Bible I have
the Sabbath that's enough and so that's
what I was going with for years you know
go to church and then I moved to LA
started to have a little more success
and um so now you're starting to get
some clarity and you're walking with God
and then the devil gives you la which is
your dream and your goal which is
interesting yeah so right before I left
I was at a church that is a a a real
Bible believing Church Richmond uh
Church in Vancouver British Columbia uh
Elder Bill Wong wonderful man and uh and
a brother named Israel who I don't think
is there anymore but they said to me you
know Eli we hear you're getting ready to
go to La we don't think you should go
it's Sodom and Gomorrah and I said well
I can bring the gospel to La you know I
can be a light in a dark place which you
find any rationalization when you want
something right yes you do and the devil
will put arguments in your mind but at
that time the world was such a different
place preo it sure was and the things he
was saying I was like this seems
fanatical there's no way the government
is going to to try and control you know
a society there's no way that the
Catholic church is is secretly running
all of these institutions these things
there's no way that this could actually
be true and I I said no this is silly
and I and I I remember getting my car
and I drove to LA and started
having interactions with the Enemy
almost immediately so I I got there I
got a role on the show called The 100
mhm and tell us about what exactly the
100 is about though before you talk
about okay so the 100 is a is a series
for the CW I remember getting the script
and I knew immediately it was going to
be a hit show um it's a series about a
post-apocalyptic
Earth where there's been some kind of
disaster that forced everyone to leave
and live in a space station and then
after a period of several centuries the
Earth has now become habitable again and
the space station is deteriorating
and so the people on the space station
decide that they're going to send their
children almost like a Lord of the Flies
type situation back down to the Earth to
run the Earth to in to to reinhabit it
and then once it's if it's safe then
send the rest of humanity down and so
they send 100 young people down to the
Earth to of which you are now one in
this and of which I'm now one in this
series and so um and so lots of stuff I
could say about just getting that role
but nevertheless I got the opportunity
and as we were going through the
contract
negotiations I said you know I'm a 7th
Day Adventist and I really want to keep
the Sabbath uh so can we get it in my
contract that I don't have to break the
Sabbath you were thinking ahead I was
thinking ahead thinking ahead of trying
not to compromise exactly what you had
found to be present truth exactly and
negotiate so how did they respond and so
they immediately said well you you know
you can't do that absolutely not because
as you shoot on a movie set you start on
Monday maybe 5: in the morning but
because you always end up going over
time and they have to have a 12-h hour
turnaround Tuesdays maybe 700 in the
morning and then by Wednesday it's maybe
12:00 noon is your start time then by
Thursday you're starting at 3:00 p.m.
and so Friday nights are always Fridays
are almost always night shoots right and
you're almost always going to have to
work on a late Friday night that's just
part of the business which yep I I
remember my days in Hollywood same
exactly and so we see the enemy having
an impact even in how he formats and
structures this industry nevertheless
you cannot keep Sabbath exactly so that
no one can keep Sabbath and so I said
well you know I'd really like to do it
and they said well we'll tell you what
we'll do we'll get it as something
called best efforts and I said what's
best efforts they said well if it's any
way we can get you off we'll have you
off but if it's an emergency you know
just just have to work with us and I
said well that sounds reasonable how
many how many emergencies could you have
could there be what you don't understand
is inol everything's an emergency ex
exactly exactly and uh and so the very
first week I got to Vancouver we were
shooting it shot in
Vancouver and uh Friday I see Eli all
night shoot just Eli it's I had a
monologue scene and I said that can't be
right they chasing they're making best
efforts I said I'm thinking okay I go to
the producer I say I say no I think you
guys made a mistake this says I'm
shooting all night on Friday and it's
just me I said I'm the only one who
asked to not be on Friday and and they
said oh yeah but Liza did this and you
know other characters in the show they
had other obligations and you know D D D
D D long story short you're going to be
working and I'm calling my agent they're
like no this is it like you know you're
under contract and if you don't do this
then you're out of Hollywood then you're
well then you've broken your contract
right and that's a legal you've now
committed a crime yep and so I was like
you know in the pressure and all that
stuff and I said
okay so then we ended up shooting we
shot until maybe like it was we shot
until the light was coming up M until
morning and I was too tired to go to
church you know and it was a miserable
thing they had a water cannon on us it
was a raining scene and I was horse I it
was a scene where I was giv this huge
monologue and the whole time I'm
convicted and it was done
well after we shot that we shot we shot
the pilot episode we find out it's
getting picked up I get a call from my
agent they're not picking up your uh
your option I'm like what do you what is
that it means you're not going to be in
the series you did the pilot but they
don't want you they're going to kill you
off in the third episode and so that
experience showed me right away what I
was dealing with it almost felt like
contempt for the fact that I had tried
to stand up for myself and at that
moment I said they were trying to break
you exactly to show you who is Lord of
Hollywood ex your God exactly and so
after that I said okay I'm never going
to compromise that again I quickly had
another opportunity to uh be tested
where I had a another show that I was a
the four running candidate to get uh it
was LeBron James was doing a new show
about his life and it was a big deal
didn't end up being a good show but at
the time people thought it was going to
be a big show called survivors remorse
and they said you know we need you to do
it I said well I'm definitely getting
the Sabbath in the contract and they
said well no da best efforts I said no
I'm not we're not doing best efforts
because I know what that means now and
it's either that or I'm walking and they
said well then you're gonna have to walk
and I walked and I remember just the
peace that I felt even though I was
struggling you know you're in La you're
you're trying to get ahead and it's so
competitive I felt that peace I knew
that I was okay had done the right thing
yes you had HD the law in your heart so
so not to offend God so exact as much as
I knew how exactly and like I said at
this time I'm still living a life that
is not in alignment with the Bible but
the one thing I did know was that the
Sabbath was God's day of rest and that I
wanted to be in church on the Sabbath
and so after that uh things started to
really take off for me and I never had
an issue it was always in the contract
people knew that I didn't negotiate that
and uh it was interesting just how that
all played out because then I started to
get roll after roll and there was even
one time I was shooting on a movie
called race and I wouldn't work on a
Sabbath night and they said we really
need you and they sent a Jewish producer
okay to my apartment to say Eli you know
I'm a produce I'm Jewish I understand
the Sabbath but we need you there and I
said you shouldn't even be here right I
said you know the Sabbath how could they
get you to do and he felt so convicted
he ended up leaving he apologized God
and uh and I think he uh started to
think about his his choices around the
Sabbath as well and so it was just never
an issue again with that but the other
parts of my life didn't get changed
until later so the devil still found a
way to Temp absolutely because you know
we have to really think that the Ten
Commandments we can focus on the four
yes but God says you know all 10 are
important that's right not one of them
is lesser if you break one of these it's
like you've done away with all that's
right so now you've won the battle for
Sabbath but now you're getting poked
from all the other ends exactly well I
know we're going to have you back and
we're going to really dig into your
roles um let's fast forward to the end
how did you become completely saved and
decide to exit well yeah so basically
covid hit and in 2020 you know 2019 I
did the biggest film i' had done to that
time I was nominated for Screen Actor
Guild for a movie called One Night in
Miami I played Cash's clay and and it
just seemed like my career was taking
off I was meeting with you know all the
biggest names in Hollywood and everyone
was telling me that movie was a big deal
it was not Regina King yeah it was the
number one film on Amazon it was Regina
King who had just won an Oscar her first
directorial debut uh you know major
ensemble cast and it just took off you
know and um and that's an actor's dream
because then you can start your own
tickets exactly and and that's exactly
what happened it was kind of like I'd
finally broken through I remember my
agent saying to me Eli you know you'll
never have to worry about work again and
and you're thinking I made it and I
serve the Lord exactly that's what was
on my heart but then I started to uh see
when when after 2019 2020 comes
literally as we're finishing
rapping and I start to see I remember
one day I looked up my window I was on
Tunga you know Studio City in LA
and I just see military car military car
military car military car and I thought
what is this right and we're all on
lockdown you can't even comprehend it
yeah it just seemed out of the blue
exactly and so the first thing I thought
was you know that Ministry that I've
been introduced to before that I thought
was no way these things could happen and
so I'm like I I want to find it and so I
start looking I looking I finally find
it and um I start watching it again now
and everything now that was said then
that I thought could never happen I'm
seeing it take place right before my
eyes it goes from conspiracy to reality
yeah exactly and so you know I watched
the entire thing it was like 30 videos I
watched there were like one hour videos
I watched all them in like a day and a
half and then I started to realize okay
um I I got to I got to really consider
what kind of future I'm going to have
because the world is not going in the
direction that I really thought it was
this stuff is real and I started
watching watching another ministry as
well that started to talk about country
living and moving out of the cities and
coming out of
Babylon and I started to think okay I
think I want to get some some country
property I think I want to get out of La
you know I don't really like the way
things are going here and so some time
went
ahead and I had I had another
opportunity now to do another job and so
in my head I'm rationalizing and I'm
thinking okay I'm going this job was a
big job it was coming after one night in
Miami it was going to be my big pay job
I'll do this job I'll get my
money and then I'll get out and so
that's kind of what ended up happening
but as I was doing that job I finally
got introduced to Ellen White and to I
didn't even read great controversy the
first book I read was Adventist home and
as I read that book it convicted me that
she really was a true prophet and that
the words she was speaking were in
alignment with the Holy Spirit and with
and with the word of God with the Bible
so now you're being convicted by present
truth yes yeah and I'm also now dealing
with the reality of the show that I'm
working on is not not only is it not in
alignment with what I believe and what
I'm convicted about but it's the exact
opposite it's it's produced by Jesuits
it has Masonic elements it is uh
promoting uh Lifestyles that we don't
agree with as far as what the Bible
tells us has as we should live um
promoting a future that is not in in
alignment with what the Bible says the
future is going to be I mean everything
about it was almost opposed I would say
to what I believe and there's a
duplicity here happening because you're
trying to serve God in in faith and in
life but yet you have this Alter Ego
that has to perform Babylonian acts
exactly and and so it became really
difficult and you know like I said I had
just come out I had just started to come
into this understanding I I had had a
relationship before that and that had
ended and I started to realize as I read
the book adventus home that it was
because I didn't understand how how
relationships are meant to operate when
you're a Christian and when you're when
you're working uh in God's way and so
I'm very fresh and new to this and I
find myself in this new environment um
that is completely opposed to everything
I believe just a powerful powerful
testimony we're going to stop you here
but we're going to have you back on part
two thank you for being here Praise
Jesus thank you I want to leave you with
the words of Ellen White among the most
dangerous Resorts of pleasure is the
theater instead of being a school of
morality and virtue it is a very hot bed
of immorality vicious habits and sinful
propensities are strengthen and
confirmed by these entertainments this
has been a wolf and sheets clothing
reminding you that what you behold is
indeed what you shall
[Music]
become
[Applause]
[Music]